MATT SPENCER:
You have to tell the people
that it's gonna be eight years
'til we're back to Earth.
If I tell the passengers
that we are stuck up here
and the food is running out,
I'm going to become the next
all you can eat buffet.
-AUTOMATED VOICE:
Warning. Warning.
-(ALL YELLING)
IRIS KIMURA: Hello, Avenue 5.
This is Mission Control.
Is everything okay?
Yeah. Everything's fine.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
How can so much light
feel so dark?
I agree.
It's my TV show.
Why does he agree with
everything that's said to him?
-You hate agreeing.
-Exactly!
Your sister died in space.
I can't look up at the sky
because it just reminds me
of her,
so I can only look forward
or down now.
(GROANING)
-IRIS: It's me.
-AUTOMATED VOICE 2:
Welcome back, Iris.
Restoring smart seat
to your default settings.
HERMAN JUDD: Are you calling me
from the toilet?
When I do that,
I'm a goddamn animal.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
RAV MULCAIR: Sorry.
We're heading into the sun.
The big, yellow cancer factory
made out of lava. That one.
Burn or starve?
Well, it's nice to have options.
You know, I think I preferred it
when it was chicken or fish.
The twilight of the moron tyrant
is upon us!
I'm just a happy bride.
I say... we sit here
and wait for death.
Pray for death.
Some combination of
sitting and death.
Sorry, I'm just internalizing
a lot of panic
-and fear right now.
-Yeah...
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS,
STOPS ABRUPTLY) ♪
-But now I've done that,
and I'm back in the room.
-Okay, good.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪